[Musique]
salut maroni aujourd'hui je vais chez
gilles un agriculteur qui a bénéficié
d'une aide pour installer un réservoir
d'eau
c'est super pratique pour irriguer son
exploitation pendant la sécheresse
si vous aussi l'aide pour l'installation
d'un réservoir d'eau sur une
exploitation agricole vous intéresse
alors suivez moi c'est par là
je suis aujourd'hui sur l'exploitation
de gilles agriculteurs qui a pu
bénéficier d'une aide du département
mise en place depuis 2020 pour
l'installation d'un réservoir d'eau un
outil bien pratique pendant les périodes
de sécheresse
bonjour j l injection alors tout d'abord
merci l'accueil à nous aujourd'hui et
chaud bienvenu alors pourquoi l'a fait
la demande d'un réservoir d'eau pas ce
qu'était un moment de stress inquiétante
car mon cas car pour chaque lot et il
fallait un point d'une le système miné
commet d'un kaka a récupéré à cinq
kilomètres de mon exploitation et bien
elle a bousillé que le département il
mettait des dz a récupéré les sit in
même en profiter et après le département
va financer et comment les démarches
cela se passait justement pas ben en
moins de trois mois mais la hume mon
ballon et que la roma service en ce
moment et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui a
changé depuis que notre réservoir mais
mona - straka pour être appelé et banal
du coup tout le temps un soulagement et
remercié gilbin méfiez vous
tout comme gilles de nombreux
agriculteurs ont pu bénéficier de cette
aide afin d'acquérir un réservoir d'eau
ce dernier permet de sécuriser et
d'augmenter en la disponibilité en eau
au sein de leur exploitation ils ont
pour objectif de réduire le manque d'eau
face aux périodes de grande sécheresse
bonjour michael bonjour alexandre alors
pourquoi avoir mis en place ce
dispositif
alors le département a mis en place ce
dispositif depuis deux ans déjà
effectivement lors des fortes cas de
sécheresse et un cutter rencontrent des
difficultés à eric et l'intégralité leur
exploitation et l'achat d'un réservoir
représente un budget conséquent pour
l'agriculteur donc c'est pourquoi le
département a souhaité accompagner
l'agriculture dans cet investissement
est
notamment pour maintenir la production
pour nos consommateurs et comment faire
pour bénéficier de cette aide alors
c'est simple le bénéficiaire qui
souhaitent avoir cette aide peut se
rendre notamment sur le site du
département pour avoir accès au
formulaire et ainsi nous le retourner
avec les pièces demandées alors à ce
jour combien d'agriculteurs ont pu
bénéficier de cette aide cette aide a
rencontré un très fort succès avec près
de 400 dossiers traités à ce jour par
nos services merci michael merci
alexandre
grâce à cet accompagnement du
département les agriculteurs peuvent
avoir l'esprit tranquille même en cas de
sécheresse comme beaucoup d'agriculteurs
gill a été accompagné par un conseiller
tout au long des démarches un suivi qui
permet aux bénéficiaires d'être informé
le plus rapidement possible sur
l'avancée du dossier
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide pour
l'acquisition d'un réservoir d'eau
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous voulez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons à la
rencontre de monsieur revol à la plaine
des cafres qu'a pu bénéficier de travaux
dans son logement place aux dispositifs
département pour l'amélioration de
l'habitat
[Musique]